Доброго дня Зараз ми знаходимось
під таким дуже важливим для України
місцем під музеєм АТО але Дивіться що
робиться через дорогу через дорогу люди
божанського замість того щоб просто хоча
б відповісти на те що взагалі слуги
народу робили на території університету
Шевченка що порушили закон про освіту а
тут вони зараз зігнали студентів і давай
запитаємо скіль Я їм заплатила за те щоб
вони тут стояли ой Доброго дня а ви
організаторт вони не знають Чому вони
тут стоять они знают так А за що ви
стоєте просто нрави за що ви
стоєте Ага стою с не хто розпочав
війну питання
Порошенко розпочав Ні ну Неро А що
вваститеому ви дітей ви ли зараз
говорити ви про пенсіонерів вам не сором
ви дітей виставили ви дали їм гроші ви
готуєте провокації Ви спеціально це
пеніонерів окрім мене я думаю ви теж не
пенсіонер Вибачте а привели Ви сюди
дітей які стоять і не знають відповіді
на жодне
питання